Our next guest, that ring, especially true.
When two co-workers who had known each other for years
discovered something shocking
through a mutual friend on Facebook.
Take a look.
Meet Sandi Sandrick and Allan Tucker.
Two friends and coworkers with quite a story to share.
My name is Sandi Sandrick.
I was born in Phoenix, Arizona.
I am currently a trauma nurse
at Banner Thunderbird Medical Center.
My name is Allen Tucker.
I grew up in a little town in Kansas.
I am currently a trauma nurse
at Banner Thunderbird Medical Center.
When I was 11, my parents told me I was adopted.
They told me who my birth mother was
but they didn't have any information about my birth father.
Sandi and Allen are both now married with children.
And interestingly enough, have more than that in common.
My adopted parents passed away.
Then my birth mother got in contact with me.
She told me that my biological dad
would wanna know that I was okay.
She just blurted his name out
and said, "He would be interested to meet you."
So, I sent him a private message on Facebook.
And when I looked at his friend list
that's when I saw Allen's name.
One day I came to work.
I saw Sandi and she looked a little nervous.
When I saw him.
I told him that I needed to talk to him.
I needed to ask him a question.
She said, "How do you know this guy, Gary?"
And he said, "Why, how do you know Gary?"
It was kind of this unreal moment that felt right.
It was a moment that would change
their lives forever.
(audience applauding)
Okay, Sandi and Allen are here now.
Sandi, Allen, hi!
Hi, Drew.
How are you, guys?
Good, how are you?
Good, I'm so excited to talk about your story.
So, you come together, you ask how, you know, Gary,
what happens next?
He said that he was his dad.
(laughing)
And I said he was my dad too.
What is the first sort of thing that you say
after that realization?
Wow, that was quite a day.
We were busy at work.
We were doing traumas and COVID
and throughout the day it just kind of sunk in.
We have the same father and she's my sister.
Yeah.
Do you like check in and you're like,
"Hey, me again.
Okay, by the way, how crazy is that sibling thing?
Okay, I'll see you in five."
(laughing)
Okay, yeah, I mean, it's just, it's so mind-blowing
and, you know, looking back now, have you like gone,
"Wow, look at all those similarities.
Like the fact that we do the same thing."
(man in audience laughing)
Yeah, we've noticed that we have a lot of similarities.
It's crazy.
I'm just so glad that you guys have been brought together
and Allen, you have other siblings, right?
Sandi, have you met them?
I've talked to them on the phone one time.
But we're getting that arranged.
With just, work schedules and kids' schedules
and all that has been hard, but we're working on that.
Well, I have a little surprise for you both.
Please meet your other brothers.
Clint and Dustin are joining us now.
Yay!
(audience applauding)
Hi, guys!
So cool.
Oh, Clint and Dustin.
I'm so happy to meet you guys.
I feel like I'm in the middle of such a wonderful
incredible family moment.
Clint and Dustin, did you have something
that you wanted to say to Sandi?
Yeah, I'm just excited.
Well, good news.
This is a perfect example of what a family reunion
in 2021 looks like and sounds like, and feels like.
So we wanna ditch the Zoom and get you guys together.
And as soon as it's safe,
we want you to set sail aboard the Catalina Express Ferry
to beautiful Catalina Island.
Where you'll enjoy a five-night stay
in a luxury condo at the Hamilton Cove Villas
and enjoy some of the greatest beach-like cuisine
courtesy of Love Catalina Island Tourism Authority
and then you guys can-
That's awesome.
Thank you, that's amazing.
I can't wait.
Excited.
That's exciting, yeah.
Thank you, Sandi, Allen, Clint and Dustin
for sharing this with us.
We can't wait to check back in and hear all about it.
Congratulations on finding each other.
Thank you, Drew.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)